I GUESS WE ARE BLEEPING THAT.
IT IS WHAT GRAHAM IS PUSHING
THAT IS SO UNPOPULAR AND THAT'S
THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME IS BEST SELLING
AUTHOR, ANN COULTER AND JONATHAN
SWAN, A NATIONAL POLITICAL
REPORTER FOR AXIOS AND JONATHAN,
LET'S START WITH YOU.
I DID SOME REPORTING BEFORE THE
SHOW AND WITHOUT BELABORING THE
SIDE AND THIS BILL DOESN'T GO
CLOSE IN MY MIND IN REACHING THE
NONNEGOTIATABLES THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS SET OUT VERY CLEARLY.
>> YOU COULDN'T HAVE HAD A WORSE
MESS ANGER THAN DICK DURBIN AND
THEN, I HEARD IT WAS FLAKE AND
GRAHAM.
THEY SHOW UP AND GO INTO THE
THEY FREAK AND THEY ARE LIKE,
MORNING.
>> THEY MUST THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS STUPID.
THEY ARE GOING TO WALK INTO THIS
POINTS?
>> WE JUST PUT A REALITY STAR
DEVELOPER IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
WHY?
BECAUSE HE TALKED ABOUT BUILDING
THE WALL.
>> I'M ACTUALLY SURPRISED AND
THEY DIDN'T TRY AND DRESS THIS
UP AND IT IS WORSE THAN THE GANG
MIGRATION AND ALLOWING THE EIGHT
TO SPONSOR UNCLES, AUNTS,
PARENTS CAN STILL FOR THE THREE
YEARS REVOLVING PERIOD OF TIME.
>> IT ALMOST SEEMED TO ME
CONTENTIOUS OF WHAT THE
OUT ON PURPOSE?
MORON.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR MONTHS AND THIS IS WHAT
THESE BOZO'S CAME UP WITH?
>> THE WHOLE ARGUMENT FOR DACA
IS THEY DIDN'T COMMIT A CRIME
AND WERE LEGALLY NOT RESPONSIBLE
AND THE AMNESTY BILL PROTECTS
>> THE IDEA THAT CHAIN MIGRATION
IS REAL AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
CITIZEN
CITIZE
CITIZENSHIP AND IF I TRIED TO
GET MY PARENTS TO COME HERE AS A
U.S. CITIZEN, IT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN MANY MORE YEARS.
>> 80% OF ALL RECIPIENTS THIS
YEAR WERE FROM CHAIN MIGRATION.
AND THE OTHER 20% WERE
JOB-RELATED.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO MAKE OF
THAT.
MY EYES ARE BULGING.
>> IT HAS BALLOONED IN THE PAST
20 YEARS AND BALLOONED MORE THAN
ANYONE THOUGHT AND WE ARE GOING
DENVER, COLORADO.
JUST THE ISSUE OF CRIME ALONE WE
HAVE TO KEEP FRONT AND CENTER
BECAUSE IT RELATES TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> THAT'S HOW MY BOOK BECAME A
BOOK ON IMMIGRATION AND IT WAS
ONLY GOING TO BE ONE CHAPTER AND
I LOOKED UP WHAT COUNTRY IS
GOING TO WANT TO KNOW AND HOW
MANY ARE IN PRISON AND THE
COUNTRY SPECIFICALLY SUPPRESSES
THAT INFORMATION AND THE MEDIA
ON A COMMENT BY TRUMP.
AND THE HAITIANS SEEM TO BE
WIDELY OVERREPRESENTED IN OUR
PRISON SYSTEM AND AMERICANS
WIDELY UNDER REPRESENTED AND FOR
THOSE THAT WANT TO KNOW THE
FACTS AND CAN YOU COUNT?
IT IS NOT THAT HARD TO FIGURE
OUT HOW MANY IMMIGRANTS ARE IN
PRISON.
CAN YOU COUNT THEM?
HOUSE?
STEPHEN MILLER AND HE'S ONE OF
THE ORIGINAL TRUMP ITES AND DOES
STEPHEN MILLER HAVE INDEPLANES
AND -- INFLUENCE AND I KNOW THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS HIS OWN MAN AND
RUNS HIS OWN SHOW, BUT DOES HE
HAVE INFLUENCE?
>> HE DOESN'T POLICY LIKE
STEPHEN MILLER DOES AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE ISSUES WHERE TRUMP
HIMSELF HAS VERY STRONG, HARD
ARE LIBERALS IN THERE THAT WOULD
HAVE HORRIFIED BY THE COMMENT
THAT HE MADE TODAY, BUT THEY ARE
BASICALLY GIVING UP AND THEY
ALWAYS DERILED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENT AND EVEN IF
HE AGREED TO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
INSTINCTS AND IF YOU WANT TO
HAVE DACA, YOU HAVE TO GET RID
OF CHAIN MIGRATION.
>> AND HE'S THE MAN ON THE
STREET ON IMMIGRATION.
HE'S IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> A YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND
TWO WOMEN.
A YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICAN MALE IN
CHICAGO AND TWO WOMEN AND THEY
SAID, I'M NOT RACIST AND I
BELIEVE IN IMMIGRATION, BUT THIS
IS WRONG AND PEOPLE ARE MAD.